[Narrator] And this can be done in a single line of code.
You construct the list W by appending
the output of the function measurement_prob() applied to the [i] particle
with the argument of the actual measurement,
and as you can see over here most of them look insanely unlikely.
So, they have exponents -146, -24.
Some of them are more likely--the ones that are closer to the truth like -5.
Those are the particles that should really survive,
whereas those ones over here with a -126,
those are really ready to die off
because they are so far away from the truth we really don't need them anymore.
So, in the final step of the particle filter algorithm,
we just have to sample particles from P
with a probability that is proportional to its corresponding W value.
Particles in P that have a large value over here
should be drawn more frequently than the ones with a small value over here.
How hard can that be.